interaction so friendly so pointed
resist the temptation of starting to
discuss what you've said figure out in
the idea that cabin or would not be
literary text
other my friend junkie an affair I hope
you invite him someday one of the great
German is translator of Hagar marks
further amazon has brilliantly I don't
think he's the only one who have done it
brilliantly compared to and more
recently I found to my amazement and lie
and say the celebrated phrase mocks his
cabin all the expropriation of the
expropriated that everybody knows which
I had already some time ago traced back
to Masonic passage in Isaiah in the
Bible where it is said and you will
impress your oppressors has its exact
equivalent the passage in Moby Dick
where kept in a hab insulting the way
in advance exclaims and hi I i will now
dismember my dismember
well thank you so much for the
invitation I'm incredibly grateful to
the mezzo process once again and the
French department and the ICS for giving
me the opportunity to talk but Europe
and its crisis here today and I thank
you for coming at such short notice
moment in the day in which i know that
most of you have many occupations
I want to before even I start reading my
text below me to regroup phrase which i
just found in fact from an article
published a few months ago August 29 in
Washington Post by when on American
pundit jars cochin how you can ask
eruption culture the European Union is
dying not a dramatic or sudden death but
once so slow and steady that we may look
across the Atlantic one day soon and
realize that the project of European
integration that we've taken for granted
over the past half century is no more
and then come several pages of
illustration of that idea
I indeed suspect and you see that I'm
not the only one in doing so that
dramatic event has been taking place at
some point during the past month which I
would describe as the end of the
European political project or the
project of transforming Europe into the
post national entity within given
borders and through the cooperation of
various nation states which shared a
common history admittedly complex and
conflictual and also as a consequence
could unite around a certain idea this
was not a project of suppressing the
constituting nations but of limiting
their sovereignty in the name of Greater
interdependency and solidarity it has
now collapsed whether this end is a
puzzle or negative phenomenon both in
terms of the interests of the European
populations and people's whether it
marked an absolute reversal of the main
tendencies of contemporary history or a
shift in the balance of forces between
elements which always opposed it or buy
it excuse me a forces I was too quickly
between elements which were in favor of
the emergence of a new political entity
called Europe or the European Union and
elements which always opposed it or buy
it for different reasons and with
different interests or indeed the simple
manifestation in the open
of a situation which had already been
there before in particular at the moment
of the failure of the grand
constitutional project in 2005 weather
finally this end is just the end of a
political project in the narrow
institutional sense of the term leaving
in place and perhaps liberating the
capacities of other elements of the
European construction such as the
economy the capture the society even the
bureaucracy or it also means that all
these elements will find themselves
increasingly paralyzed and dissociated
which I tend to believe could be the
case but I certainly don't have any
certainty in this respect these are all
questions that I offer for reflection
and discussion supposing that you could
agree on the fact of the event itself or
the accomplished end of the European
political project but of course there's
nothing edited here and since my
conviction on this point was first
formed in the moment of the so-called
Greek crisis in the last spring I would
need first to return to my reflections
at this time which I expressed in the
form of a set of theses published in the
French web John or internet journal
media part and also partially
on the English newspaper The Guardian
and now if you are interested to be
found on the online John or theory and
events published by the johns hopkins
university press vol 3 issue number two
of two thousand and ten now which thesis
did I propose
the first teases was that the financial
crisis whose effects were dramatically
affecting the Greek budgets and as a
consequence threatening the European
banking and monetary system was only the
beginning with in one single month we
had witnessed Prime Minister Papandreou
whose revelation of the real Greek debt
which had been up every day almost new
revelations about that which had been
manipulated by his predecessor with the
help of Goldman Sachs the announcement
of his country's inability to repay
hugely increased credit interests an
expensive European rescue loan offered
to him and his country on the condition
of devastating budget cuts all this soon
followed by the downgraded rating of the
Portuguese and Spanish deaths a threat
on the value and the very existence of
the euro currency the creation of a
European security fund fund worse 750
billion euros the Central European banks
decision against explicit rules to bail
out some sovereign debts in case of
necessity and the announcement of budget
austerity measures in several member
states these were the latest episodes of
a crisis and local episodes
of crisis which had started two years
before with the collapsing of the US
housing credit and which seemed to
forecast others until today they remind
us that there is more than ever a risk
of financial crash provoked by the huge
amount of rotten stocks which have been
accumulated over the last decade through
the combination of unwarranted loans and
the transformation of credit-default
insurances into financial products for
speculation there be cunning recoverable
deaths like the blackjack in a card game
what in france we called mystically a
changing place and denomination and the
states that is the taxpayers can't catch
up indefinitely the short-term
speculation was now targeting the
currencies and the public deffos the
euro appeared and perhaps still is I'm
not an expert the weak link in the chain
and so did Europe itself for many
serious economists there can be little
doubt that catastrophic consequences are
coming
the second thesis was that the Greek
protest popular protest was and remains
essentially justified a first immediate
effect of the toxic remedy the pride of
the Greek crisis was the angry protest
of the Greek population it is debated
whether this should be seen as a coward
denial of the populations own
responsibility or no more healthy
rejection of an unjust collective
punishment leaving aside the criminal
episodes which have interfered at some
point it seems to me that the protest of
the Greek was fully justified for at
least three reasons first we have been
witnessing and completely insane
denunciation of the whole Greek people
not only in European journals and forums
but also in other parts of the world
including the US the corruption and the
lives of record editions whose
beneficiaries as elsewhere as everywhere
are essentially the rich cultivating tax
evasion on a grand scale were blamed on
the people are such indiscriminately
second once again the government had
betrayed in electoral promises without
any form of democratic debate last
Europe did not display any real
solidarity towards one of its member
states but imposed on it the cursive
roots of the International Monetary Fund
which protect not the nation's but the
VEX and promised deep and endless
recession most serious economists agreed
that this would spread the crisis
possibly needing even more innovatively
to a default of the Greek Treasury in
any case rising the already high rates
of an employment especially if the same
rules we're imposed on other countries
whose rating of the financial market
could become downgraded at any moment
the in famous pics portugal ireland
greece and spain which incidentally was
exactly what the overlooks party was
asking for the thirties is was that we
should consider all these phenomena and
tendencies not as the inevitable effects
of economic constraints more or less
inevitable but as politics which is
hiding its name
the Greek were the first victims that
they can hardly be the last of a
politics of rescuing the European
currency who strategy dispositions
mainly imposed at the time by Germany
but also backed by others are first and
foremost the general restriction of
public expenses and in addition a rather
my control of speculation and the free
movements of hedge funds and traders
already announced several times after
the crisis of the subprimes and the
actual of virtual crash of the u.s.
banks of some big US bank in 2008 to
this New Keynesian economists I would
return to this added another request to
move as rapidly and as completely as
possible towards the creation of the
European economy government especially
in through the unification of tax
policies possibly also correlating and
enhancing industrial investments for
want of such measures they claimed a
single European currency would prove
unsustainable none of these measures
indeed are purely technical they are
entirely political measures which all
citizens ought to be allowed to debate
because each and every of us will be
affected
by their outcome however to the extent
that it exists the discussion remains
deeply biased because the central
determinations are hidden or pushed
aside any policy of defending or
devaluing the currency in the conjecture
of crisis leads to a radical alternative
either it subjects the economy and
social decisions to the power of the
financial markets including its rating
criteria working as self-fulfilling
prophecies and it's a need to be
absolute wise judgments or it adds to
the capacity of the state and more
generally the public institutions to
limit the markets instability and grant
long-term economic interests a primacy
over short speculation but it cannot be
both in its current form under the
influence of the dominant social forces
the European construction may have used
some degree of institutional
harmonization this is the second end
I suggest is brushed aside may have used
some degree of institutional
harmonization and generalize the
protection of some fundamental rights
which is certainly not negligible
although often more verbal than real
witness the recent vicissitudes of the
European would be indignant of friends
on the issue of Romani roaming freedom
of circulation but contrary to the
stated goes it has not produced any
convergent evolution of national
economies zone of shared prosperity far
from some countries are dominant others
are dominated with respect to shares in
the marqus or concentration of
financial capital or industrial autonomy
the people's may not have antagonistic
interests but the nations and the states
increasingly do third any Keynesian
strategy to generate public trust in the
economy rests on three independent
pillars a stable currency certainly a
rational system
taxes but also a social policy aiming at
full employment or as well as possible
and increasing the popular consumption
to sustain the demand this third aspect
is systematically ignored in most
current commentaries obviously not by
chance the false ceases that I believe
to be relevant to the situation
concerned the real trends of
globalization underpinning the visible
manifestations of the crisis all this
debate concerning the Euro monetary
system which let us not forget some
important European countries still still
don't want to join including the United
Kingdom but also Sweden and Poland and
the future of Europe would remain
entirely abstract unless it is
articulated to the real trends of
globalization precisely those strands
which the financial crisis will
powerfully accelerate unless they are
politically addressed by the people's
which they are fat and their governments
how can we summarize them first
we're witnessing a transition from one
form of international competition to
another no longer mainly the convention
among productive capitals but a
combination among national territories
which use tax exemptions and pressure on
the wages of Labor and ever-increasing
insecurity of jobs to track for more
floating cabin oil than their neighbors
now whether Europe works as an effective
system of solidarity among its members
to protect them from so-called systemic
risk or pushed by powerful states who
are momentarily more efficient or better
protected from market fluctuations
simply sets a theoretical framework to
promote a greater degree of competition
among the member states and their
citizens this will determine the future
of Europe politically socially and
culturally but there is a second
tendency which must be taken into
account maybe a transformation
international division of labor which
radically destabilizes the distribution
of employment in the world this is a new
global structure we know where north and
south east and west all denominations
which and the show will last forever of
course are now exchanging their places
for Europe or most of it if not
counteracted it will entail a brutal
increase of inequalities a collapsing of
the middle classes the shrinking of
skilled jobs a displacement of so-called
volatile productive industries a
regression of welfare and social rights
the destruction of cultural industries
and general public services this is why
resistances against supranational
political integration which believed to
protect the sovereignty of the states
will in fact we can the defenses of each
singular nation they will also
precipitate the return to the ethnic
conflicts which the European
construction wanted to overcome forever
this is in fact already well underway
however and it's one of the points on
which captioned
your choices however it is also clear
that a greater political integration of
Europe cannot become created from a bar
by some bureaucratic decision it
requires democratic participation and
advances in each country and the
continent as such this leads me to the
fifth thesis which takes the form of a
question admittedly a risky one which
concerns the meaning of so-called
populist movements in Europe is it
essentially apparel for democracy or
could it become also a resource we
cannot but ask the question is this
crisis the beginning of the end for the
European Union a construction that had
started 50 years ago on the basis of an
age-old utopia but now cruising able to
fulfill its promises I'm afraid that the
answer unfortunately is yes as I said
already a moment ago sooner or later
this will be inevitable and possibly not
without some violent term on unless
unless it finds the capacity to start
again on radically new bases Europe
isn't that
project but the breaking of the European
Union would inevitably abandon its
peoples to the hazards of globalization
to an even greater degree conversely a
new foundation of Europe does not
guarantee any success but at least it
gives her a chance of gaining some
geopolitical leverage in her own benefit
and perhaps the benefit of others with
one condition however that all the
challenges involved in the idea of an
original form of post National
Federation Confederation I don't mind
the term are seriously and courageously
met and as the failure figure of
previous attempts would seem to
demonstrate they are anything but you it
is a question of setting up a common
public authority which is neither a
state nor nation-state even bigger
a nor the simple governance of
politicians and experts of securing
genuine equality among the nations thus
fighting against reactionary
nationalisms whether on the side of the
strong on the side of the week and above
or of reviving democracy in the european
space thus resisting the current
processes of d democratization or as i
suggested some years ago statism without
a state produced by new liberalism and
the colonization of its administration's
by a bureaucratic cast which is also
partially the source of the corruption
in the public markets something obvious
should have been long acknowledged there
will be no progress towards federalism
in Europe the one that is now advocated
by some and rightly so in my opinion in
parenthesis I disagree in this whisper
with prominent French analysts including
on the left in the goalie stand Mitchell
and East traditions such as former
Minister of Foreign Affairs affair
between the one who coined the name
hyperpower for the United States with
whom I recently debated this issue in
the French John or God she doesn't even
magazine so there will be no progress to
its federalism in Europe if democracy
itself does not progress beyond the
existing forms the lower and increase
influence for the people's in the
supranational institutions does this
mean that in order to reverse the course
of recent history to shake the letter G
of a decaying political construction we
need something like a European populism
in other terms a simultaneous movement
or a peaceful insurrection of popular
masses who will be voicing their anger
as victims of the crisis against its
others and beneficiaries and calling for
the controller from below over the
secret beginnings and occult thieves
made by markets banks and states yes
indeed there is in fact no other name
with which we can call and become
political of the people I agree that it
can lead to other catastrophes which is
why we need strong constitutional roots
to be observed and above all political
forces to emerge again in the European
arena who introduced the culture of
uncompromising democratic ideals and
imaginary into this post national or
populism this of course makes very fixed
set of carnage of conditions but the
risk is greater it seems to me in a
felon nationalism prevails in whichever
for this leads me to my final thesis
again in the form of a question where is
the European left in some parts of the
world giving this one forces aiming at
the kind of peaceful insurrection that I
have just mentioned were traditionally
called the left but the European left
also is now bankrupt nationally as
transnationally in the broader political
space stretching it across borders that
is now relevant it has lost every
capacity to express social struggles or
lounge in
very movements it has surrendered to the
dogmas and Russian at ease of neoliberal
of Alexei consistently it has been
ideologically disintegrated deprived of
any strong popular support namely the
left political party in Europe today
which would have social support those
parties which represent its nominally on
now powered as spectators and
commentators of the crisis for which
they offer no specific and connective
response they have remained passive
after the financial shock in 2008 still
passive when the International Monetary
Fund resides which in other times on
other continents they had vigorously
criticized Argentina etc were imposed on
Reese passive again when it was proposed
to rescue the Euro at the expense of
wage labourers and ordinary consumers
and they proved unable to launch a
public debate on the possibility and the
needs of a Europe of solidarity we may
well wonder in these conditions what is
going to happen when the crisis enters
its next
it's select next to me next faces when
national policies increasingly
repressive lose their social contents of
their remaining social alibis there will
be protest movements almost certainly
but then we find themselves isolated
possibly they will become deviated
towards violence or recuperated by
racism and xenophobia which are already
searching or around us in the end they
will produce more powerlessness more
despair this is tragic since the
capitalists and nationalists right
itself now on the offensive is also
strategically divided it was clear when
stopping public deficits was pitted
against investment policies and it will
be even more the case when the very
existence of common European
institutions is at stake there was an
occasion to see a strong word to say
about but the question also and it was
not sent by the left but the question
also concerns the intellectuals what
should and
be a democratically elaborated political
action against the crisis at the
European level walking walking excuse me
on both legs economic administration
social policy eliminating corruption and
reducing the inequalities which faster
its restructuring the restructuring
depths and defining common objectives in
order to legitimize transfers of tax
resources between mutually
interdependent nations it is the task of
progressive intellectuals whether they
see themselves as reformists or
revolutionaries to discuss this subject
and take risks and here if I had time of
course I should open the parenthesis
which could be long to say that there
are indeed initiatives in that sense but
they come from individuals or from very
limited groups
of intellectuals however not deprived of
course of influence and clout in some
cases two examples come immediately to
my mind which I want to one of them is
the so-called manifesto of European
concerned citizens of manifesto from you
Europe signed by ash I mean another
saskia sassen in particular which is in
that university has posted it in fact on
the so-called half the Huffington
published in the New Statesman and races
and the second one which is more recent
the so-called manifesto of a pawn of the
afford economists this is more fatigue
friendly derision and also exist in
English you can find it on were very
depressing test these were the questions
that I was trying to formulate a few
months ago and wanted to publicly
discussed in the wake of the Greek
crisis incidentally this crisis is not
over it has only disappeared from the
television screens for months later I
keep thinking that they are inevitable
even if I repeat I can admit that I have
not found for each of them the best
possible formulation for this reason I
will try in the second part I talk to
add clarifications and therefore further
nourish the discussion on two points
which certainly are not the only ones
which needs such clarification they
concern the relationship between
democracy and populism and the
reciprocity
economic and political determination let
me start with a short populism which is
probably the most dedicated especially
what you speak before an audience which
I suspect broken shares the values and
historical perspectives of what a moment
ago I call the left incidentally a
debate about the oscillations in meaning
in the meaning scope and effects of
optimism is perhaps easier to start on
this side of the Atlantic in a country
where the category has a long and
complex history and remains used in very
contradictory ways i noticed that
president obama was called populists
when he lounged an attack or attack
against the tyranny of wall street and i
notice of course that the term is also
used to quantify
I have used this term I'm going to go in
complete awareness of the terrible
ambiguities which characterize its use
and meaning I believe that they belong
to the essence of the political
indicating an intrinsic risk that
politics which wants to escape
abstraction and take into account real
forces acting in a given conjuncture can
never avoid they also point at the issue
on which the democratic politics must
concentrate its efforts both in terms of
mobilization and clarification the
popular movement which today is so
dramatic it so dramatically missing must
be reconstructed it must also indeed in
the middle of dangerous circumstances
require a moral and intellectual
capacity to resist certain deviations
without forgetting the lessons of tragic
experiences in the past in the debate
which is perhaps starting about the
renovation of the left and the
resurrection of politics of the European
level other contributors prefer to
insist on a civic commitment rather than
a need of populism which i perfectly
understand since I have myself long
advocated in other places an extension
of the category of citizenship in the
active sense including its ethical
mission at the trans national level but
I do believe that we need to use both
notions let me try to explain political
theorists but it should be political
theorist and philosopher an historic low
well known certainly audience has
insisted that the dominant conception of
politics stigmatizes the notion of
populism not only because of its
association with nationalism and even
racism but because the political
institution is viscerally opposed to the
direct to any direct intervention of
popular masses in the field of politics
which would so we're told distort the
play of constitutional rules and put
democracy itself at risk in the eyes of
the privileged and ease such a notion is
also an obstacle which makes it more
difficult to adopt and carry on
unpopular policies so what very often
the category populism designates while
referring to innumerable examples of
demagogic and dictatorial regimes
serving as alibi perhaps the name Chavez
last example is also in fact a
supplement or in excess of democracy
with respect to its early gothic and
elitist definitions which involves
active participation protests campaigns
extra-parliamentary continues or
organized mass movement and this country
just as europe is not poor in records
for such moments and movements but in
the absence of such movements democracy
soon becomes an abstract world if not a
mystification democracy requires the
crystallization the visibility of the
demos of the multitude in other terms
the majority which it officially
represents not to suppress the
parliamentary and representative
institutions in general the division of
powers the protection of individual
rights and the rights of minorities but
to recreate an equilibrium of social
forces the possibility of more
egalitarian access to power compensating
the influence of economic power wealth
social relations based on expertise and
professional hierarchies and family ties
and academic solidarity's in short on
class membership the current
developments in our European countries
especially in the field of economic and
social policy
eloquently illustrates the consequences
of the complete imbalance of forces
between the early gawky and the majority
nobody is really able to dispute the
decisions which are proposed or imposed
by governments of global or
transnational administrations whose main
effect is to transfer unto the ordinary
people the burden of depths which have
been generated by the anarchic
speculation of the markets or the
irresponsible budgetary decisions of
governments this is generally designated
euphemistically as a you as a democratic
deficit of our officially democratic
regimes which was blatant in the Greek
case but is no less observable when
other European governments including the
French the Spanish the German the
British adopt austerity policies which
are very far from the programs to which
they had committed themselves at the
time of the elections in particular
because they neglect the dramatic
questions of poverty and
I should avoid misunderstandings here
nobody who is serious when dispute the
fact that critical circumstances may
impose changes even reversals of
political orientations but you cannot
consider that it is democratic to
carefully exclude the population from
the information and the discussion when
it comes to determining the content and
the extension of the changes take the
example of the conflict on retirement
age and pensions today in France which
has equivalents in other countries by
the way if you read this morning young
time there is a new total precisely on
that France the unions and fiscal
reality would be worth discussing
and what holds at the national level is
even truer at the supranational or
communitarian level where some of the
most decisive measures are taken for
want of a European democracy including
debates in the population and the
emergence of parties in the broad sense
mobilizing citizens across the borders
you only have what you only have our
negotiations no to say bargaining mum
national governments and politicians are
much more interested in flattering the
prejudices of their electoral basis then
encouraging their actual participation
we have to do here with a permanent
floor of the European Union perhaps it
is not the only coast why the Democratic
life within each nation tense now to
degenerate or become blocked but
certainly it does nothing to improve the
situation governments I don't believe
that the amount of democracy in the
national and supranational arena is
something like a system of communicating
vases if you have more less democracy at
the European never you have more on the
national level and
conversely is just the opposite when you
have her last at the supranational level
you also have less and the national
level and conversely this is what we
observe governments use the European
institutions when they find it
convenient in particular to picture of
the political choices as technical
imperatives or constraints imposed by
the supranational bureaucracy but they
nor or downplay them when something like
a transnational public sphere seems to
be emerging which they would not control
there was never a question for the
European Parliament to seriously examine
the financial bailout or the
articulation of monetary and budgetary
policies in Europe the parliament in
this sense is even less than an advisory
body this is the fear or as my colleague
and friend Jacques Mossler would put it
a hatred of democracy which proves
terribly self-destructed in the long run
it leads to complete loss of legitimacy
for politics the governmental and
representative institutions themselves
whether at the National on the European
level since the two as I said just a
minute ago cannot be separated for that
reason it has become the task of the
people's which taken together a form a
virtual demos at the European level to
revive the Democratic principle without
which there is no possibility of a
legitimate
government and of State Board
institutions which means that the
national people's must learn to reject
the policies based on the continuation
of privileges or even their development
in the context of the crisis this is why
I spoke of the need of a European
populism which is not the opposite of
civic values and commitments but it's
complementary side in a given critical
conjecture in other terms I am NOT I am
far from ignoring that the most visible
and active forms of populism today in
Europe rapidly expanding throughout the
continent have nothing to do with a
peaceful insurrection of citizens coming
from different countries in the name of
democracy in order to remove the early
gothic structures as we know it is
mainly a nationalistic and local
populism strongly xenophobic even
potentially murderous with respect to
alien populations the migrants
especially those who come
the other side of the Mediterranean and
the Islamic cultures but also the Romani
nomads perhaps even the Jews and in many
cases the other Europeans pitting
against one and other people from the
north and the south and east and the
west of the continent sometimes the
k'tralli or economically diverse regions
within the same nation as you can
observe in Italy or in Belgium but there
is another form of populism that is
equally destructive of democracy which
is dramatically illustrated by the
Berlusconi type of government and now
also increasingly the Sarkozy type in
France this is a populism of the media
as my friend and colleague Giacomo
Mahama professor at university Oh McClay
Rome three calls it whose technologies
of the manipulation of the mass media
record in a soft manner the past
examples of the fascist era is it so
soft we too have the equivalence of
course of your rationing goals in Europe
all these are reactionary papa disease
occurring occurring each other
throughout the continent which expressed
the deep demoralisation of
popular classes and the middle class but
also result from silicone maneuvers of
the ruling classes and ultimately the
lack of a post national perspective to
confront the tendencies of globalization
in an active manner and the shrinking of
social movements against the absolute
rock rule of profits the question that
becomes is it thinkable that they can be
resisted and defeated only through more
or predication of humanist values
anti-racist lessons of history the
theoretical defense of the benefits of
the rule of row and the liberal
civilization but without ever touching
the mass inequalities and the crashing
domination of corporate interests and
financial networks I don't believe so on
the contrary I think that we need a
genuine popular search which initially
must take the form of a protest against
the type of society in which the major
and it lives
day but I'm fully aware that there is a
huge risk involved in such formulations
reason why I insist simultaneously on
the need of a commitment to democratic
principles and the need of a reformist
program which does not limit itself to
stigmatizing the early jockeys and their
contempt for the majority but opens
constructive perspectives especially in
the economic and social real do I have
something like another 15 minutes or is
that yes
though be sincere I messed up there okay
my sacred promise thank you this leads
me to discuss always in the form of
working hypothesis the issue of the
relationship between politics and
economy the first difficulty here comes
from the fact that if we are not
professional politically Spurs we
believe nevertheless to understand
something of the political processes
quite citizens whereas most of us feel
disarmed before the complexity of the
economic choices we're continuously led
to accept simultaneously the idea that
the economy sets the absolute condition
of politics and that they belong two
separated reals but isn't this precisely
an ideological representation the
dominant discourse has developed a whole
series of categories to carefully hide a
fact that the recent crisis nevertheless
has brought back into the open the fact
that everything in the economy is
political just as everything in politics
is economically determined I'm not
thinking here only of the broad three
conditions or the after effects but of
the processes themselves and their
intrinsic contradictions they do not
obey intro or mechanical laws they
consist when they consist of
relationship
so forces and they open bifurcations
choices if you prefer let me try and be
more precise before I conclude by
returning to the lessons of the
conjuncture that I was evoking in
relation to the Greek crisis and its
origins it is widely acknowledged that
the political choices after the American
subprime crisis have not cancelled the
risk of financial crash but disseminated
them in particular fruit transference of
the deaths from the private banking
sector to the public treasury and the
national economies but this seems to
involve more fundamental structural
lessons which concern the articulation
of state and capitalist market a first
lesson is that the crisis of public
finances beat in the case of Greece or
Spain or Britain or France have nothing
to do with a pure quantitative of
budgetary calculus which would why I I'm
excuse me I'm absolute objective
indisputable results in practice it
entirely depends on momentary decisions
without a single decide errors made by
the financial markets the ratings of our
agencies Moody's Standard &
so their evaluation of the capacities of
states to keep repaying the interests of
their deaths and the rates of interest
imposed on them when they need to borrow
on the financial market in order to be
able to continue paying previous
impressed the more difficult it is for
country to face its obligations the
higher the cost the coast of money
becomes for it as a consequence there is
a fluctuation in the death of states
which affects their in their autonomy
ultimately their degree of sovereignty
the states are rated by the financial
markets as private firms or communities
would be now the markets are anything
but an impersonal and disinterested
mechanism they're largely controlled by
great banks and speculative funds or in
any case for want of real regulation
they mainly serve their interests in
that sense banks and hedge funds have
become political actors in the strong
sense quasi-sovereign acted in fact
since they can impose two states central
banks and governments the terms of their
economic and monetary policies social
clearly this has devastating
consequences on the capacity of
traditional political bodies such as
people's or nations of citizens to
choose and determine their own
development it would seem that the only
country today in the world which
partially escapes this inverted
relationship between the public and the
private is the virtually hegemonic
Chinese Empire but certainly not the
United States of America renowned french
economist Michel a gita has recently
insisted that there is no conciliation
possible between the two opposite logics
of the regulation for the regulation of
financial markets but others concur with
him on the same point either the public
authority imposes imposes rules of
precaution and transparency on the
speculative operations or it is the
unlimited demand for liquidity which
produces a quasi absolute day of
deregulation but there is no middle this
is a political alternative in the field
of the economy through the intervention
of Finance which can be properly
compared to conflict of rival
sovereignties a crucial observation in
this respect however is that in the
current age of globalization the public
order in
which is likely to regulate the
financial operations and control the
banks in the public interest is not
necessarily in the nation state or in
stock exchange regulating agencies of
course there are states which prefer to
completely serve the logic of the market
particularly to keep their function as
international places of trade one thinks
of the City of London and they would
never acordes officially a retreat in
their sovereignty on the contrary
they're presented as a form of
resistance to the abusive intrusion or
imperialism of a Brussels authorities
but above all there is this difficulty
which Europe clearly does not so maybe
the fact that even wealthy nation states
are no longer in a position to
effectively regulate the markets by
themselves isolated from one another
supranational or transnational
regulations where the power of control
and coercion would be necessary which
nobody either knows how to install or
wants to install there's a European
Central Bank with there's no European
equivalent of the SCC but there is
another face to this competition among
states on the background of a
globalization process dominated by
financial logics which also affect the
relationship between the national
policies aiming at developing the
competitive power of territories their
capacity to attract floating capital and
the level of social inequalities I'm
speaking of inequality love salaries
welfare benefits therefore the quality
of life in general which are correlated
to the policies of lowering salaries
developing the insecurity of employment
through the use of underpaid migrant
labor and to the competition among tax
regimes which in the long term
inevitably affect the social services
and the social security it would seem
that in this respect the states are
regaining at least part of their
sovereign capacity to politically decide
the economic conditions of politics
which a moment ago I said was slipping
into the hands of financial private
actors clearly depending on their
political orientation states in today's
world either put the emphasis on the
conservation of a certain murder of
social security or we tend to create
capacity to export cheaper goods and
keep or increase their commercial
standing but obviously this possibility
of choice is taking place between very
narrow limits on the one side there's
the fact that the murder of social and
economic development supported by the
state cannot be chosen at we're
independent of a place that a state
occupies in the world economy and apart
from the similar choices made by other
states which sometimes are much more
powerful and on the other side there's
the fact that the political choices
affecting social inequalities which in
the end will produce either the
inclusion or the exclusion of whole
populations are more or less easily
tolerated by the citizens in other terms
they are not exposed only to the hazard
of international competition but also to
the effects of what until recently
Marxists and some others designated with
the name of class struggles I thought
that these general considerations
however imperfect tech
on the combination of economic and
political constraints revealed by the
crisis were necessary to address the
difficulty that is involved in the
discourse developed in particular by New
York Keynesian economists and
politicians rather influential on the
left and back from outside by such I
mean in Europe by such influential
theorists as for example portrait man or
joseph stiglitz from columbia university
they have insisted that a coalition of
states like Europe should increase its
capacity to limit system interests and
regulate the financial market they have
criticized a mere perspective of the
reduction of deficit the politics of the
deflation and more or less control
depression as it is advocated by
neoliberal galaxy to eliminate the
wealth of accumulated debts and suggest
on the other side the new institutional
capacity of governing the economy in the
general interest a voluntary stick
policy of counter cyclical growth
supported by the public budgets my
feeling is that such proposals which
certainly are not absurd and would be in
the interest of the majority are very
difficult to implement conceivably
without a radical
with the existing regime of political
and economic power which seen from the
angle of democracy I called early gothic
a moment ago the fact is that the real
power is now again largely displaced out
of its official juridical administrative
and parliamentary sites but the
fashionable term governance mainly
covers is the development of a shadow
Constitution of power which was best
illustrated by the way in which the IMF
and certain European governments
cooperated in the definition of the
financial rescue plan imposed on the
Greek government and people but it is
equally difficult to implement these
reformist policies if a tendency towards
increasing inequalities among
populations keeps developing as a
consequence of globalization not only
outside the European continent but now
increasingly inside its limits both in
terms of national territories and in
terms of regions and sectors or sectors
of activity you cannot think in fact
that you will increase the degree of
competition among the European up
without also inevitably increase the
level of inequalities potentially
disruptive as they are apparently framed
in national categories ultimately the
political changes required to implement
reformist economic policies are so
radical that to conclusions are possible
either a new keynesian perspective
including the particular conservation of
the welfare the existing welfare system
of what remains of a welfare system is a
complete utopia in the framework of
neoliberal globalization as we observe
in today or reformist policies are
indiscernible from a break with the
capitalist system in other terms a
revival of what I would call with a
lander into my friend and I value the
socialist hypothesis more white reforms
that remain to be invented in particular
to eliminate the specter of socialism in
one country which is still now I have
little doubt personally that regulatory
ideas and I yours with a socialist or
even a communist character are needed to
invent a policy or program which would
counter the domination of financial
capital on the economy and the social
life particularly if we refer the idea
of communism to its etymological root
the notion of the common common interest
common good action and thinking in
common as suggested today among others
by antonio negret but i would not like
to enter speculations on this theme
which I don't think has much immediate
utility I prefer to some what's which
the debate in order to conclude these
are really my last developments to the
discussion of the forces involved in a
struggle around different ways to
confirm the crisis which will either
solve it or aggravate it and above all
will not benefit the same elements of
society this in a sense we will be back
to exactly the same issue of democracy
and populism that I had discussed a
moment ago or bite from different angles
I said that the specter of the class
struggle is more than ever overing over
the transformations of the relationship
between the state and the market however
it seems to be extremely unlikely that
the forces of the camp's confronting
each other in a political battle for
democracy involving an titanic kinds of
populism could be described simply as
classes in the traditional Marxist sense
or even as class alliances as
perscription theorists like Nico's
Collins's suggested some 30 years ago
but they can also not become pictured in
terms of an apocalyptic entities ease
between entities like the Empire and the
multitude or a mass of the people who
would just be awaiting the political
program or an ideological symbol to
revolt against the tyranny of Wall
Street things are more complicated it
seems to me and for that reason as well
the political perspectives are much more
uncertain which is one of the reasons
why a leftist imaginary for which the
form which the binary representations of
social conflict are quasi foundational
finds itself so disturbed and designed
which in turn tense periodically to
precipitate the Socialists on the Social
Democrats into the traps and the dead
ends of the so-called third ways why is
it not as simple as a binary concept of
antagonistic forces would suggest it is
not I believe because the
ss have been mystified by dominant
ideologies like nationalism or religion
fundamentalism if you like however
misleading and damaging you you see us
that inclusive they can do it is also
not because here and there the state and
more generally the bureaucracy is not to
forget the powerful corporations
creating networks of dependency or
corruption which profoundly permeate the
society and destroy the Civic spirit
although it would be silly to deny that
this phenomenon is very clear but I
think that a much more decisive factor
comes from the fact that the life of the
mass of the multitude is profoundly
integrated in the fabric of financial
capital from the point of view of its
employment more or less precarious its
daily conditions of life its consumption
its culture its survival in the
community sense of the term some of our
contemporaries use the term biopolitics
to designate this dependency but it
would be another discussion to say that
there is integration is not to say that
there is no integrity that the material
interests of the masses are the same as
though
financial capital or represent a minor
function of them it is to reject the old
idea that of the financial capital as a
parasitic capital the notion that was
developed in the 19th century as a
reaction against the scandals of
financial speculation which had indeed
the equivalent today on an even larger
scale and under the influence of the
productive 'used ideology of the
Industrial Revolution which Marxism in
fact largely shared what the subprime
crisis what the subprime crisis
demonstrated in particular was the fact
that the most elementary conditions of
life what to parody agamben am tempted
to call bear life such as housing for
the poorest members of the population in
the United States but also in Britain or
other countries is immediately dependent
on the access to credit facilities which
itself forms the large and largely
fictitious basis of the speculations of
the banks and insurance companies so
that individuals and masses of
individuals who are excluded rejected
into the margins by the system are also
in a sense even more tightly integrated
into it we could borrow the expression
inclusive exclusion proposed in other
intense or to quote another recent
example when the Bay him off of oil
industry called British Petroleum was
threatened with penalties by the US
administration because it was held
responsible of the ecological
catastrophe in the Gulf of Mexico as
soon as the market value of its stocks
seemed to vacillate the huge pension
funds which earned his talks rang around
there and could present themselves as
speaking in the interest of the ordinary
people to describe all these facts we
could use the expression that marks coin
had caught in a marginal corner of his
manuscripts preparatory for desk avatar
that left lovely unemployed that of the
real sub sumption of the workers and
more turning the population under the
process of accumulation of capital this
became really significant and altered
this patterns of social conflict only
when the primacy of industrial capital
was replaced by the primacy of financial
capital and the latter had established
an intimate association with the
structures of mass consumption covering
the life and culture of the whole
population including the pool it is
always on the side
the tool that there is money to be
harvested for the rich even if the poor
have no money under which consequences
are we going to derive which
consequences are we going to derive from
this hypothesis first of all it seems to
me the conclusion that there is no
exteriority of the interests of capital
and the interests of the population an
idea that is still shared by many
reformists while not radicals or
communists themselves again this does
not mean that there is no antagonism or
no contradiction but antagonisms armor
vertical they are traversing the forms
of life the patterns of activity and
consumption the interests and
accordingly the forms of consciousness
of the social groups there is a struggle
undoubtedly but which does not so much
separate pre-existing rules defined in
credit of terms then antagonistic ways
of socializing or collective izing the
interests of individuals and to some
extent these individuals are the same
they belong to the same classes
same nations same professions each time
incompatible ways of governing the
society with an economic political and
also a moral dimension part involved one
is tempted here to borrow aggression
formula and suggest that the country is
among alternative Hegemony's and
corresponding historic or blocks which
does not mean that certainly interests
have primacy over others such as
competition all solidarity financial a
cumulative or sustainable growth
imperial domination or the hybrid ation
of cultures etc but that individuals and
social groups can make a choice between
different ways of life different modes
of survival of course this kind of
choice is not really free it having a
depends on the conditions created by the
place where you are located in the world
which is itself highly confusion and
hierarchy whether Europe not killing in
advance any specific
limit to that the extension of that name
could prove to be in the place of one of
the places where the similar choice
remains meaningful is something are not
able to decide myself of course thank
you